peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais écrit une chanson après tu
battre caen nord avec des parents leur
fait-on les musiques le genre l'or
mon style je me suis dit c'est la place
et ça devrait pas être difficile il ya
de la demande dans ce métier y est
montrez capdevielle
l'apocalypse jeunesse j écoute ma
vieille femme à peine deux cas la crise
samedi soir un ange qui marchant le
service 12 aces poignardant ciel étrange
le carton des follicules
avec vers les vestiaires du crépuscule
tous les gardiens de la nuit lequel
jouer les funambules
voilà ma chance en compote si tu en veux
pas
j'ai armé
l'ofj et tu sais pas ce que tu fais
on lui a pas plu
non pas
complet
m
[Musique]
une chanson un truc en plus super les
paroles en béton avec une musique
d'enfer correspondait pas trop à mon
image bon créneau quand le coach italie
dachau cbi la foule
j'ai rencontré la ville
à geoffroy-guichard dans l'enfer vert
immaculée de raconter mon histoire
passez à new york depuis venus effrayé
par un blake au point d'un blog
très singulier où il n'était pas présent
les blessés seulement qu'il est parce qu
on fore leader
en bilan dans la ma chance aux montois
cidre
jodar melandri culotte arrive à y voir
clair
normal
[Applaudissements]
la guitare et à mon trip solaire de rim
j'ai travaillé très très tard j'ai fait
une chanson sublime j'espère
abbott qui m'ont dit c'est pas pour toi
sur une chanson de votre mère conseil au
village car ces rencontres et cabrel
assis au bord nous ferons je dis ma
chanson s'appelle le chemin de la route
et c'est l'histoire d'une autre
un caillou dans sa vie a plus personne à
nicole
l'ambiance est faux elle de retrouver sa
terre et ses chèvres et services fuir le
doter la poussière et revoir sa
normandie voilà ma chanson popote
s'il revoit pas des barjots larvée dans
ma culotte ou au pire d'envahisseurs
majan fonds lui a pas plu
n'en parlons plus
alors je suis de passage mais plus que
les chansons pour moi je pense être une
aussi sec qui raconte l'histoire d'un
mec amoureux de sa mobylette et leur
amour est impossible
m
qu'ils nous y faire
mais qui meurt en mangeant une canette
de bière à mobylette celui ci en faisant
couler yale a créé en led finir en est
ce qu'ils croyaient en acier et c'est
sur cette fin parole de sterbik ma
chanson payet et si elle vous a pas plu
vous savez où je me la mets
façon elle sera pas foutu
parce que maintenant michael je vais
dire c'est un patchwork qui médit baitha
quatre chansons farfelues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]